we did a story last week with Ben and
Jimmy about whether we in the media
should be talking about Isis when they
do these propaganda videos with the
beheadings and the burnings and all the
other awful stuff how much we should
actually talk about it because that does
that just strengthen them does that
strengthen their recruiting etc etc well
now our Justice Department apparently is
going to go after people who are
promoting Isis on social media we've got
a little more info for you John Carlin
the assistant attorney general for the
national security said that officials
could try to blunt Isis's violent PR
operation by trying propagandists as
terrorists he suggested the Justice
Department could bring prosecutions
under the law against providing material
support to a terrorist organization this
may be the first time a US official has
ever said that people who assist Isis
with online media could face criminal
prosecution okay
on its head that sounds pretty decent
right we don't need them to be using our
tools like Facebook and YouTube and
Twitter and things of that nature to
promote this horrible stuff on the other
hand we all talk for a living we talk
about these things we report on these
things etc etc this seems like a
slippery slope for someone like you
right right so I'm not a big fan of
slippery slope arguments but I think
that when you start passing policies
that criminalize and prosecute people
for simply promoting a terrorist
organization through commentary it could
be really dangerous
and if it's commentary through social
media under what these officials are
asking for hey you know what you're in
big trouble you could be prosecuted I
don't know if you're gonna be tried for
treason I don't know exactly what the
charges against you will be but at the
same time people are allowed to have
their opinions even if their opinions
that you disagree with even if their
opinions that you find extremely violent
or destructive so for instance we allow
the KKK and white supremacist and
neo-nazis in the country to say whatever
it is that they want to say because we
protect their speech right now actions
are completely different so if you're
going out of your way to recruit people
into Isis if you are actually doing
something to physically help Isis I
think it's a different story but I think
common
Terry and speech should be protected
even if it's something that you disagree
with yes I am a hundred percent onboard
that and there's a difference of course
between free speech and calling for
violence against people but what do you
think about the slippery slope thing
because to me it seems like yes we might
report on it I might think it's
important that someone knows what
they're up to so I could tweet a link to
an article that doesn't mean I'm
supporting them if anything I want to
show people this horrible stuff but then
there's the slippery slope to the
government could be like are you promote
what are you what are you going for here
well yeah I mean there's an important
differentiation which Ana just made but
at the same time I'm not sure if I buy
this like it seems like it's more
posturing than actually fixing the
problem and then there's also the idea
that a legislature usually moves way
slower than technology and then we have
a problem because of that this seems
like it's a little bit in the opposite
direction like it's too much yeah do you
think that the timing of this is also
we're like I feel like we live in a time
when nobody trusts the government to do
the right thing anyway
the government's spying on us all that
stuff NSA and all that so the idea like
there isn't enough trust there isn't
enough cachet in what the government is
doing to be like oh we trust that you're
gonna deal with this thing populace the
timing is interesting because we live in
an age where the government gets to do
things without real authorization right
so we're seeing certain executive
actions when it comes to foreign policy
without congressional approval and like
that war in Syria yeah exactly so that's
problematic to say the least but I think
that the slippery slope is definitely
possible in a situation like this
especially when in the past we've done
stories about people who have been
prosecuted for let's say posting rap
lyrics on their Facebook page right
officials will make the argument that
they're promoting rap violent not rap
violence gang violence that this is
dangerous that they're actually going to
carry out what they're saying in the
lyrics but it's speech and and you
really need some hardcore evidence to
prove that someone is going to carry out
a violent act or that someone is
inciting violence yeah so to that point
do you think we need to have like a real
debate about what free speech is in this
country and what freedom of expression
is because I feel like with the Charlie
have another thing and everything else
we're not debate we're not
talking about what really most people I
don't think understand that the
difference between what you say and then
inciting actions like things like that
yelling fire in a movie theater like I
feel like we have to have like a real
discussion about it but we don't and
then as you're both saying then the
government can just go ahead and be like
oh we're gonna do this little Isis
Twitter thing and who knows where we end
up yeah I mean a lot of it it seems like
it's reactionary to you know just weird
things going on I also think people
don't really understand the difference
between freedom of speech and freedom of
expression which one of them protects
you from you know the authorities and
the government the other one is just
kind of being a dick and one of these
legal and one of them you know yes right
I think another really good point is the
fact that a lot of Americans don't
understand what it means to be protected
by free speech so for instance if a
company decides to fire you over your
speech they have the ability to do that
right a private company free speech
protects you from any government action
or you know strike back if if you say
something that they don't like right all
right what do you think is this a
slippery slope to the government
controlling the Internet even more than
it already does or are we actually gonna
help stop Isis three means like this let
us know in the comments right down below
[Music]